okay let's talk about black widow for a
second
you know this is an interesting movie i
still say that it should have come
out before infinity war or avengers end
game
but the fact is that we got it now and
given the way the movie ended
it's probably not a bad thing but it
leaves a lot of stuff open and i can
definitely see
why they released it now as opposed to
releasing it at a previous point in time
because the reality was that in the time
frame where you had the movies coming
out that were going into avengers in
game and infinity war they were all kind
of segwaying into it and so there wasn't
a whole lot in the way of
the ability to produce a movie like this
and have it have it basically be
open-ended where it's like the black
widows will return
dot dot dot and then go into like
avengers end game right that
it just it would seem a little off and
so i can definitely see why they
released it now but
let's talk about a few things right so
the red room um i think i have all this
stuff explained on comics explain the
red room the red guardian
i don't know if we ever made a video on
black widow now that i think about it i
feel like we should if we haven't
already but there's a lot of stuff to
know here right a lot of things to go on
you know starting with with the idea of
the red room and with the red guardian
when they first announced that red
guardian was gonna be part of the black
widow movie my initial thought was
okay cool we're gonna get the winter
guard and then as they started releasing
trailers like obviously you know you saw
a red guardian he looked like the kind
of guy who's like you know back in my
day he was
older and it's like okay so this isn't
gonna be the winter guard
i don't know what this guy's backstory
is gonna be but it's not gonna have
anything to do with the winter guard
what's the winter guard okay so in
marvel comics the winter guard was
russia's answer to the avengers the idea
of the avengers coming together
presented this kind of threat in the
eyes of russia of okay so like the
united states now has a superpower team
so what russia did is they started
traveling around their country and quite
literally
snatching people up anybody that had any
powers was just conscripted
into the russian superhero team the
winter guard not all of them made it but
some of them did so
getting into the red room itself if the
winter guard was
russia's answer to the avengers then the
red room was russia's answer to weapon
plus
weapons plus was a joint venture between
the united states cia
and canada's department h slash
department k all this stuff you'll find
links all the stuff down in the
description over comics explain but the
cool thing here is that with weapon one
because of the fact that captain america
was frozen in ice
weapons plus started going through and
launching a whole bunch of other
programs so you had weapon 2 weapon 3
weapon 4
all the way up to weapon x also known as
wolverine and so the whole idea of the
red room was to basically create
russia's counterpart to wolverine that
if wolverine was going to be
this kind of assassin super
soldier-esque character that would
basically be a step ahead of everything
captain america was
then russia wanted to have the same
thing and that's where the red room
comes from the red room is basically
exactly
what you saw between all of black
widow's appearances which is
the desire to create these enhanced
super soldiers that can
basically carry out assassination
missions the funny thing about this is
that if you're going to read marvel
comics the origin of laura kinney x23
is actually far more close in line with
the story of the red room than wolverine
is right that's kind of a weird and
a little bit of a wonky thing but the
important thing here is that there's a
point in the movie
when there's a statement made by molina
which is the technology and the stuff
that she was working on
started in the states and then she took
it to russia there's no reason to
believe that they can't use this to
basically
launch wolverine right to introduce
wolverine because they say it started
with hydra
and i have a video where i basically say
like here's how you do introduce the
x-men into the mcu
you start with wolverine and you
basically say that hydra was the one
that did it right so i think it works
perfectly right if y'all if you say it
all started with hydra but nonetheless
there's cool stuff that goes on there
right it's one of the reasons why black
widow can have a
huge impact on the future of the marvel
cinematic universe if it's done
correctly having said that i loved red
guardian i loved the lexi he was
hilarious
i loved his character he was awesome i
was praying to god over the course of
the movie that he wouldn't die
thank god he didn't i was afraid they
were gonna kill him and molina off
at the very end when like they end up
kind of careening down in that jet i
thought it was gonna crash and they just
kind of
silently write them out and like they
find their bodies just sort of just
spread all over the place and it's like
oh my god they didn't make it you know
or something like that
i was really hoping that wouldn't happen
and it didn't
i'm so glad to see he's staying there
i'm really curious to see what role they
play because one of the things that kind
of comes out of this is that we have
like the avengers right we have
the whole avengers landscape avengers 1
avengers 2 infinity war and avengers
in-game now's the time for the new
avengers right and i could easily see
them launching the winter guard
based on the new avengers right
basically saying okay so like russia is
going to now have its own avengers team
that operates as a kind of compliment to
the avengers
from from the united states now the
reality is they weren't really friends
right it's not like you saw a lot of
team ups between the winter guard and
the avengers i mean they worked together
if the threat was big enough but by and
large it was you stay away we stay away
that kind of a thing with regards to
black widow because of the fact that she
was kind of the missing link right kind
of the connection between these two
things and she was one part avenger and
then one part had a
really one part black widow with a
russian heritage i could easily see that
kind of bridging the gap but there's no
reason to believe that like they would
all be friends right he's like well we
all knew black widow okay cool let's pop
some beers
cheers everyone like i don't think
that's really gonna be the case
so you know it's it's it's going to be
interesting to see how it unfolds
i loved absolutely loved black widow's
sister oh my god i loved her character
she was fantastic honestly and we all
pretty much
know she's going to become the new black
widow there's no reason to indicate
that's not gonna be the case right
and i'm looking forward to that i'm
excited about that right i love that
idea
of her becoming the new black widow in
the marvel cinematic universe she fits
the role perfectly
especially when you get to the
post-credits scene and you've got the
whole scene with uh with valentina
which by the way wow like i never
thought we would see that kind of like
post credits crossing over
between falcon and the winter soldier
and like the black widow film right
literally valentina is the post-credits
scene
not even a post-credit scene she like
meets with uh with us with john walker
u.s agent right and then you see in a
post-credits scene here it's cool man
like i love seeing that
this is what it originally should have
been you guys remember back in the day
when you had like daredevil jessica
jones luke cage
that terrible iron fist show like you
guys remember all that this is what it
should have been
this is exactly what it should have been
like but the important thing here is
that these these little bit of
crossovers these post credit scenes and
stuff like that
that's cool right and we know that she's
basically gonna go after clint martin
now which i think is gonna be a little
bit of history repeating itself right
she's going to go after clint martin
clinton barton's going to tell her what
actually happened
that he and natasha were really good
friends they were besties they probably
banged i don't know why they wouldn't
have but they were like besties at one
point
and then in turn like you know they were
fighting over who was going to sacrifice
their life for the infinity stone right
you know your sister was honorable she
was a great person and i would have
given my life for her and i tried to and
yada yada so on and so forth and they're
going to go forward as friends right
like that kind of thing is going to
happen i don't really think she's going
to go forward as like an enemy of clint
barton and just be like you're lying
about the whole thing with voromir
there's no way that's true even though
it probably is because stranger things
have happened but regardless i loved her
character but i love the portrayal of
her character having said that
let's talk about taskmaster right
because this is the other thing that i
think a lot of people want to know about
you let's talk about taskmaster
you know a lot of people are pissed that
it's not tony masters i wouldn't say i'm
mad
i would say i'm more disappointed
because i really wanted to see tony
masters in the mcu the biggest issue i
have with taskmaster is why the
character even exists in the first place
right like it seems like the whole idea
of taskmaster was kind of an
afterthought
right like everybody sat down they made
the black widow movie and they said we
need
a thing that happens in the film that is
the motivation for why she has this dark
and tragic history this thing we've been
alluding to over the course of her
appearances
in the marvel cinematic universe and we
needed to tie into budapest and so as
they were thinking about this they said
you know what let's have her kill the
daughter of the guy she needs to kill so
she can get to the guy
in order to kill him to escape from the
black widow program and then get to
shield
and then we'll just have this little
girl come back later on as taskmaster
the motivation's just not there right
it's just not it's flimsy
it's it's really really really really
flimsy one of the things that i did like
one of the things that i loved
is they kept the idea of taskmaster
here's the funny thing about tony
masters and marvel comics right again
it's not tony masters in the movie but
the concept remains the same so tony
masters was born with basically muscle
memory
he could look at what people were doing
and then his muscles would memorize it
now over time he actually consumed a
serum that enhanced that ability and it
actually pushed them to the point
that as taskmaster fights an opponent
not
only does he basically learn to fight
the way they do he can actually predict
what they're going gonna do
before they do it most of the people
that attend task master school
are usually villains right like
crossbones is a good example of that you
guys remember crossbones from the marvel
cinematic universe right you guys
remember him
and the comics he basically trained at
taskmaster school and there's a lot of
other people who have but there's also
heroes that train with taskmaster
captain america has trained with him
wolverine's trained with him shang chi
spider-man a lot of these guys have
trained with taskmaster because
fighting him is fighting a whole host of
enemies but all in all
i wouldn't really say that i dislike the
idea that taskmaster is a girl my
biggest issue is that this seemed like
the the motivation for why
taskmaster exists is flimsy at best at
the very least
you know i am glad to see the taskmaster
is continuing on because i'm not gonna
lie
my biggest fear is that marvel was gonna
kill her off and i was like man like
marvel kills their villains man
like marvel it's the one thing that i
hate about the marvel cinematic universe
i love practically everything else you
talk to anybody who's been reading
marvel comics long enough and they will
tell you
william striker magneto apocalypse
depending on who's writing them
more often than not the villains are
more interesting than the heroes
and the marvel cinematic universe kept
killing them off
and it was pissing me off to no end so
i'm so glad to see
that taskmaster survived until the end
of this it feels like the marvel
cinematic universe is finally learning
its lesson like okay
maybe we should stop killing the
villains fingers crossed it lasts for
any real measure of time
but regardless the movie was cool is it
the best thing there ever was
no black widow just seems to fall pretty
short right it just doesn't have that
kind of
pizazz that like the other movies had
and i think a lot of that's based on the
fact that black widow's not really an
exceptional character
she's just a really capable chick who
fights well and so it's kind of hard to
craft a solo movie around that
that's very very compelling especially
in the face of a movie like black
panther or doctor strange so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end
thank you guys for watching let me know
what you think about the movie down in
the comments and i will catch you all
later
peace